okay so we're back we have a huge week
this week this is
um tonight donald trump is going to hold
what will likely be his last political
rally as president in georgia
in support of incumbent republican
senators kelly leffler
and david perdue even though he's been
insisting that the georgia senate races
are rigged
he's still saying go and vote for kelly
and david
um we're going to cover that rally live
tonight
tomorrow are the two runoffs in georgia
tomorrow night we will cover
results live as they come in and then
wednesday january 6th
vice president mike pence is going to
preside over a formal counting of the
electoral vote
in front of a joint session of the house
and the senate
and we have learned that some
republicans are planning
to try to steal the election from joe
biden who remember won by
quite a bit this is the biggest attack
that we've seen
on the fundamentals of democracy in the
united states in a very long time
the term sedition is being used and i'm
here to tell you
that yes it is disgusting and no
it will not work so let's go through it
so that you understand why
these are delusional ideas uh uh that
are being put forward
by republicans that on january 6th
mike pence can choose instead of
counting the actual
electoral votes for example from
pennsylvania biden won pennsylvania
democratic electors voted for joe biden
beautiful
there are republicans claiming mike
pence can say no i'm not going to accept
those electoral votes
i'm going to accept these alternate
republican electoral votes from
pennsylvania
he can't do that mike pence cannot do
that that's not going to happen
that's a fantasy mike pence doesn't have
that power
mike pence's role in this is strictly
ceremonial
but what we are going to see are
objections
from the floor from both some house
republicans
and some senate republicans to the
counting of the electoral votes that
have been
legally cast by electors right now it's
expected that there are going to be 11
republican senators who will claim
i object because of irregularities
and they will ask for an emergency
10-day audit to investigate now remember
they've been investigating two months
not a single court has found any of
their arguments meritorious
now the really scary part is that
because
of the fomenting of baseless anger by
trump and others
there are expected to be multiple
rallies and gatherings of trumpists in
dc on wednesday
and there are fears of violence a
variety of groups are expected to be
there
there are threats of violence calls for
an armed encampment which sounds a lot
like that
chaz and chop thing that trumpists were
denouncing over the summer when it was
over the george floyd protests
but chas and chop only wanted to govern
themselves
these lunatics want to govern the entire
country by imposing
an unelected president on the united
states we've come to expect that
hypocrisy i won't dwell on that today
and they're even calling there are even
some republicans calling for violence
cuckoo congressman louie gohmert for
example
said in effect the court ruling would be
you gotta go
to the streets and be as violent as
antifa and black lives matter that's
louis gomer former judge
saying that attorney lynn wood who's a
pro-trump lawyer that's been at the
center of a lot of this nonsense says
mike pence should be executed for
treason so many
allusions and incitements to violence
going on and we'll see what happens on
that front on wednesday but the bottom
line
what happens voting wise on wednesday so
here's how it will go
some republicans will object to the
counting of the votes
it will trigger a couple of hours of
debate in each chamber senate and house
and then there will be a vote about
whether to uphold the objections
neither the house nor senate will vote
to uphold the objections
and joe biden's election will be
certified that's what's going to happen
so all of this weeks of planning and
plotting and threatening
this will lead to a delay of a few hours
on wednesday
and we will cover all of it live for you
they are attacking
our basic democratic systems and they
should be held accountable
uh it's unclear if these republicans are
going to be held accountable
but this is really the last thing we
need in the middle of a pandemic that
has dramatically been mishandled
where we have an urgent need to put
someone else in charge of managing the
pandemic
joe biden already has a team already has
a task force they've been meeting
they've been working
and there couldn't be this there would
it would never be acceptable to attack
democracy in this way
but this is an acutely bad time to do it
so let me know
on twitter what you expect to see happen
on wednesday you can find me on
twitter at d pacman start your day
and your new year off right with just
egg
which is one of our sponsors you've
heard me talk about the importance of
having a diet that is
more heavily plant-based than it's
something i've done
over the last few years i've always
loved eggs
so it's great that there is a delicious
plant-based
version of egg with all the protein of
egg that just egg brings with it
but it's made from mung beans so it uses
98 percent less water
and causes 93 fewer carbon emissions
than a conventional
egg and just egg cooks and tastes
exactly
like a conventional egg i've tried it
for omelets
scrambled eggs french toast banana bread
pad thai anything you'd normally use
eggs for and i actually think if i
cooked something for a friend without
telling them
about just egg they wouldn't even know
the difference
find it in the egg aisle at your grocery
store
on amazon prime now or on instacart
and they also have a frozen version
perfect for breakfast sandwiches
just egg try it out